Hello everyone,
this lecture
will be the
pharmacology of
Parkinson's and
Alzheimer's disease.
So with Parkinson's
disease, it's going
to be the loss of
dopaminergic neurons
from the substantia
*****, and the patient
will present with
tremors, rigidity,
slowed movements,
and the main drug
here is going
to be L-DOPA, which
is going to be
sort of a precursor
to dopamine.
And with that medication,
we also have other
medications that are
also used to prevent
the breakdown either
of L-dopa or dopamine
itself. So in the
lecture, I'll go through
each class and I will
identify the adverse
effects. I will also
explain drugs which
can induce a Parkinson
-like effect. We call
it EPS and that is
known as extrapyramidal
side effects. And
that's going to be very
true with the drugs that
block the D2 receptor,
and those are known
as antipsychotics,
first generation.
I will also review
the pathogenesis of
Alzheimer's, which in
this case, we have a
deficiency of
acetylcholine. So the main
treatment is going to
be to increase this
neurotransmitter, we
in the past few years
have had the development
of monoclonal
antibodies that actually
will bind amyloid
protein and that would
help someone that was
maybe diagnosed
recently because we use
those for, you know,
early diagnosis of AD.
so with parkinson's
disease again it's
about the dopamine
and its loss in the
substantia ***** with
both conditions whether
it be pd or ad
patients are going to
have some degree of
change in say their
affective disorder
so what i'm trying to
say is they'll present
with depression
anxiety they'll have
a certain degree
of say delusions
some hallucinations
so it's going to be
necessary that other
medications are
going to be put on
board to kind of
manage those symptoms
what i also need to
mention is that with
both disorders they
tend to happen in
older adults and
what we tend to have
as patients become
older in the elderly
population, there
are other medications
that are oftentimes
needed, whether it
be something for
hypertension, hyperlipidemia,
the patient
may have atrial
fibrillation, they may
have COPD or asthma.
And here is where you
need to closely evaluate
all the medications
because there can
be an exacerbation of
adverse effects, and
I'll try to go through
them in this lecture
or they can even be
drug interactions. So
it's important to know
when you're dealing
with these populations
you really have to look
at the big picture.
Not just dealing with
the neurological
component but everything
else that might be
affecting that patient.
So antipsychotics,
these are the first
generation. They block
the D2 receptors,
and they're going to
block in the mesolimbic
area, which is
responsible for
causing some of that
disorganized thought,
those delusions. And
that will, in fact,
help the patient that
is experiencing
a psychotic
break, so to speak.
And that would
be something
that we would want
in those cases. But
if you block D2 in
the tuberal infundibular
pathway, or you
block here in the
nigrostriadium, you're
going to get number
one, an increase
in prolactin. And
I'll cover that when
we get to the
antipsychotic medications.
And here you're going
to get the patient
experiencing a degree
of movement change.
So that is something
that we need to
understand. And I will
say that now the typical
antipsychotics,
those that block D2,
have been widely
replaced by the atypical
antipsychotics. And
those block more than
D2, they block
serotonin. So we'll talk
about the differences
and some of the adverse
effects of those
other drugs coming up.
The other thing
with emesis,
understand that
emesis comes from the
area of postremia
in the brain.
We call it the
chemo trigger zone.
And in that area,
we have muscarinic
receptors, we
have D2 receptors,
we have serotonin
receptors.
So if you gave,
say, a D2 receptor
antagonist like
prochlorperazine,
that patient, of
course, would be
better. They
won't be vomiting.
but if they had something
like parkinson's
disease they could
get an exacerbation
of the symptoms so it's
important to understand
that even though
again for emesis we
have newer drugs like
the serotonin blockers
you need to identify
medications that
have this d2 block
because it can in fact
induce some of
these symptoms that
you're trying to treat
in your pd patient
And then we have
another medication.
It's known as a vesicular
monoamine transporter
2 inhibitor. It's
known as tetrabenazine,
and we use this
for Huntington's
disease. And this
medication, by blocking this
specific transporter,
is going to deplete
monoamines, including
dopamine. So, patients
that are using this
for Huntington's may
experience some effect
on their movement.
So, again, understanding
the loss of
dopaminergic neurons
in the nigrostriadium
and the effect
that we talk about
when we use those
D2 blockers is
called EPS, extrapyramidal
side effects.
So it's thought
that PD can
come from various
mechanisms.
The first one is
going to be glutamate
being the excitatory
transmitter
binding to its
receptor, NMDA.
And this glutamate, as
you know, is responsible
for exo-citation,
basically. okay
excitability and it does
so by this increase in
calcium so the more that
you get excitability
the more the neuron
can be damaged and you
can see that in the
picture the other thing
to know is through this
increase in calcium
and through other
pathways that might be
involved in maybe in
inflammation you're going
to have an effect in
the mitochondria and the
mitochondria we know is
is there to synthesize
energy and when you
start to get production
of say oxidative stress
or neuroinflammation
you also are going
to lose energy and
that's going to result
in the death of the
dopaminergic neuron
okay and then we do have
something that might
be protective and these
are known as a neurotropic
GDNF, which stands
for glial cell line
derived growth factor.
And just as the word
says, this particular
factor when it binds
to the receptor
has been shown to
actually be somewhat
protective to the
neurons. So we'll
see in the future.
I'm sure they are
trying to develop
something that actually
enhances GDNF, but
we'll stay tuned.
And then the other
thing that's been
implicated, both
in PD and another
type of condition
that falls in that
group, it's called
Lewy body dementia,
seems to be due to
the fact that you're
getting these folds
alpha-synuclein and what
happens is it's not
the folds but there's a
misfolding that happens
and what tends to result
is an accumulation of
this alpha-synuclein
and that has been shown
to number one make
Lewy bodies and also
create neural neuronal
damage so you can
understand that that
mechanism will damage
the dopaminergic neurons.
Again, in this next
picture, you can see
there's going to be
a connection with the
substantia ***** for
dopamine and the corpus
striatum. And we'll see
a little bit later, we
do have a drug that
actually has some effects
on the corpus striatum
for GABA. In a normal
patient, you can see
that the signal for
dopamine is considered
to be strong as you
can see in that solid
red line and there's a
good balance between
acetylcholine and GABA.
In Parkinsonism you see
that the red line is
now dotted so to speak
so that shows the
loss and then there
may be some effects on
acetylcholine and GABA
because once dopamine is
lost you may increase
acetylcholine, you can
increase GABA. So we
do have drugs that can
help with those
neurotransmitters, but it's
just showing you the
difference between
normal and a patient
with Parkinson's disease.
So L-DOPA is the drug
of choice. For many
years, it's been first
line. Most physicians
are going to start
that medication first
there may be some
exceptions and the reason
being is that dopamine
if it was given
it would not cross the
blood-brain barrier
we use dopamine in
in in several um
situations like if the
patient has um some
type of cardiovascular
maybe shock but
if you were to give
dopamine as a pill,
it would not cross
the blood-brain
barrier. So it has to
be given in a L form,
L-isomer, and it's known
as levodopa or L-dopa.
This is able to cross
the blood-brain barrier.
Once it gets in,
it's going to be
converted to dopamine
by an enzyme known
as dopa decarboxylase.
and that's going
to be present in
the nigrostriadium.
One problem is, as the
disease progresses,
and again, we need to be
clear, for
both PD and AD,
both diseases are
going to progress.
None of these
are cures. These
are just to slow
the progression.
Eventually, the
patient will worsen.
But as these
neurons are lost,
the drug efficacy is
going to start
to go down.
and the other thing
is that you're
going to see
that with long
-term use patients
are going to get
dyskinesia and that
has to be really now
saying that the
patient is is having
different movements
they're going to be
fidgety they're going
to be swaying and
that has to do with
the fact that as
you're losing the
neurons, you're not
going to have an equal
distribution of the
dopamine in the
nigrostriadium. Okay.
The other thing
with L-DOPA is,
and this is, you
know, probably the
reason why a
lot of these new
drugs are added on
for this reason.
Patients are going
to have periods where
on means that they
have good mobility.
That means it's a
good period, the
drug is working,
everything is good.
In the off period, that's
when they're
going to have a
fluctuation of drug
levels and they're
going to start to
have more symptoms.
In the past,
what they used to
do is they would
take the patient
off L-Dopa for
a period of time
and then they
would reinstate and
incidentally it did not
work well because number
one you have to re
-establish a level
you have to tight
read the dose you may
get the introduction
of adverse effects
again that you have
to manage it just did
not work well for the
patient in the end
And they did see that
patients did poorly
with this phenomena
of drug holiday.
So now we have the
other drugs. And I'll
explain to you what
they are coming up. We
have the Mal-B inhibitors.
We have the Comt
inhibitors. We have
even dopamine agonists.
So as you can see,
L-DOPA's fate is
twofold. It's outside the
blood-brain barrier
in the periphery, and
what happens is that
if you give L-DOPA,
in the periphery, that
DOPA decarboxylase
breaks down some
of that drug.
So what we give
with L-dopa, and
this is the
formulation known as
Sinemet, is something
called carbidopa.
L-dopa with carbidopa,
levodopa and
carbidopa. And carbidopa
is not doing anything
for the Parkinson's
disease. it's just
preventing L-DOPA
from being broken down
so that more of it
can enter the CNS.
Because I will
explain in a moment,
you cannot go really
high with a level
of L-DOPA either,
because patients
are going to have
adverse effects
and some of them
can be more serious.
As you can see here,
and I will go through
it step by step in the
next few slides, we
do have certain enzymes
that try to break
down either L-DOPA
and that is catechol-O
-methyltransferase and
that is going to be
inhibited by the COMT
inhibitors like entacopone
or inside the CNS is
tolicopone. We have
MAO-B that tries to
break down dopamine.
So in order to stop
that enzyme from
breaking down the
dopamine and keeping the
dopamine levels up
here in the CNS, we
would give something
like seleguline.
And then later on,
when we're talking
about the postsynaptic,
we have the D2
receptors, D2, D3,
D1. And the drugs
that I'll talk about
that go under the
name of dopamine
agonists will include
drugs like pramipexole
or rapinerol.
So the adverse effects
of L-DOPA, well,
number one, I did
mention about dopamine
being in the chemo
trigger zone. So
anything that's going
to aggravate the
receptors in that area
are going to cause
the patient to be
nauseous and they will
*****. So initially,
when you start this
medication, make
sure we are doing it
slowly because that
can be something that
can prevent the
patient from, you know,
taking their
medication. If they
start feeling
this early on,
they're not going
to be compliant.
The other thing is
orthostatic hypotension.
And this means
that when you get
up from, say, a lying
down position or
you're sitting down,
you get up quickly,
you feel dizzy and
sometimes faint.
And this happens, I
think you might have
done the alpha
blockers, the sin drugs
like prazosin,
pterazosin. If you get up
quickly, the blood is
going to take time to
pull to the extremities
because of the
alpha blockade, and
you get this feeling.
This is a problem,
especially in the elderly,
and patients with PD
tends to be an older
population. So the
idea here is when you
start the medication,
not only are you starting
at a low dose, you're
going to warn the
patient, don't get up
fast from lying down.
and that adverse
effect, if we
want to say what's
the mechanism,
it may be that when
L-DOPA is given, it
may be converted to
dopamine, and dopamine
in itself reduces
peripheral vascular
resistance, and that
lowers blood pressure.
Some patients can get
an exacerbation of
cardiac arrhythmia,
so again, making sure
you're doing baseline
tests. If you need to
do, say, an EKG, that
would be recommended.
That has to do with
the fact that dopamine
could be converted
to norepinephrine,
and that norepinephrine
in the beta receptors
of the heart will
increase heart rate.
And then, of course,
if I'm talking to
you about drugs that
we use to manage
psychosis, if you're
increasing dopamine,
you're going to be
more prone that the
patient is going
to have delusions,
compulsive behavior,
and hallucinations.
And going back to what
I said, D2 blockers
take care of that. But
D2 blockers will cause
more of the problem
with the movement. So
what do you do in this
case? You may give them
the atypical antipsychotics
that I mentioned.
Something like
quetiapine or rispidone
which instead of blocking
d2 they have a stronger
blockade for the
serotonin 2a receptors
so aside from that this
is why when i mentioned
you need to keep the
dose of l-dopa at a
place where it's effective
and it's not going
to cause these adverse
effects and that
is why we give the
carbidopa because if you
gave it without carbidopa,
you might have to
give a higher dose.
Carbidopa keeps the dose
stable and you avoid
these adverse effects.
Understand that
carbidopa is
going to work
peripherally.
Okay.
Okay. So this is
important to note because
in the gut,
things will happen
to levodopa. Much
of it is going
to be broken
down in the gut.
So if you see the
first curve, L-dopa
alone, you can see
that 70% of it is going
to be lost in the
gut. It's broken down.
And in looking at
the toxicity, there
may be deposition in
peripheral tissues.
But ultimately,
only one to three percent
gets into the blood
-brain barrier. So you're
having more adverse
effects and less
in the blood-brain
barrier. And that's not
really what we want as
an outcome when you
give it with carbidopa
you're going to get less
of a breakdown in the
GI tract okay and
ultimately what you see
more is in the blood
and that is a good thing
because then it can
get through the blood
brain barrier and
you can see that the
difference is here you
get 10 percent through the
blood brain barrier
when levodopa is given
with carbidopa there are
some drug interactions
with l-dopa number
one high protein foods
will decrease the l
-dopa absorption so it
doesn't mean that you
can't have you know
eggs or steak or anything
like that but you
just need to be mindful
perhaps not give the
l-dopa during food
maybe give it an hour
before you have the meal
b6 is also interesting
in that it does increase
the metabolism of
l-dopa in the brain
periphery and it would
stop ultimately it
from getting into the
brain so again i i want
to say if you're taking
more than say five
milligrams of b6 that
would be an issue. A
multivitamin should not
really give this change
in drug absorption.
Mal-A inhibitors.
So again,
this lecture comes before
antipsychotics and
antidepressants.
You'll understand
it more when we
get to those lectures.
Mal-A inhibitors
used to be used
for depression.
If you gave one of
those drugs with L
-DOPA, you may induce
hypertensive crisis.
Okay, I'll explain
that mechanism when we
get to that lecture.
First of all, MAO-A
inhibitors are not
given anymore because
we have SSRIs, SNRIs,
we have newer drugs
like bupropion that
we use for depression,
but this would be
mainly a board concept.
And the metabolites
of L-DOPA are
similar to what you
see with dopamine.
You have homovanillic
acid and you have
dihydroxyphenolacetic
acid that we
know as DOPAC,
metabolites of dopamine.
so another drug that
can be given and
sometimes physicians may
want to give this early
on is amantadine
amantadine you'll also
see or maybe you have
already observed it
if you've done any
drugs for viruses this
medication is used
for both the treatment
and prophylaxis of
influenza A not B because
B would require
something like Tamiflu
but we don't use
this as much anymore
because again
we have other
medications we also
assume that most patients
will agree to
be vaccinated
against the flu and
that's a good thing
but for early PD
there seems to be
several things that
occur number one it
increases dopamine
release and that's a
good thing It
creates muscarinic
blockade, which will
help with some of the
tremors that these
patients may have.
And then there's that
NMDA receptor block.
And I talked about
the relationship
between glutamate,
excitability, increasing
calcium, and damage
to the neurons.
It's given ******,
so it's convenient.
But those patients that
have renal insufficiency
may need to have a
dosage adjustment.
And then the
adverse effects.
Well, if you're
giving dopamine,
patients may end up
being delusional.
They can end up
having hallucinations,
okay?
Muscarinic block
effects. So again,
throughout this
block, I'm going to
say, you know,
the hot as a hair,
dry as a bone,
the heart runs alone,
mad as a hatter,
because muscarinic
block is going to
turn on sympathetics.
It's going to
affect cognition,
creating tachycardia,
medriasis.
Patients are
going to be dry.
So that's something
to be expected.
And then there's a
skin side effect, I
want to say, known as
levito-verticularis.
Where the patient
is going to appear
to have this
like purplish net
look to say their
arms and legs.
And this has to do with
constriction of the
vessels that is
decreasing the blood flow.
They say that this may
be due to the blockade
of the glutamate at
the NMDA receptor.
So since we're doing
this, I just want
to review the
antiviral mechanism of
amantadine and the other
one is rimantadine.
But we don't use
rimantadine for PD.
So one thing that
needs to happen
is that you
need to get an
acidification of a
specific channel.
Because when that
channel gets acidified,
there's going to
be an uncoating
and that's going to
release the mRNA.
So what amantadine does,
it blocks this
M2 channel.
So if you're blocking,
you're not getting
that hydrogen ion
in, you're not
getting acidification,
and you're not getting
uncoating and
release of the virus.
The resistance with
this may be that
there's a mutation
of the M2 protein. So
you might have seen
this now for the first
time. Again, it may
be something that
you might see on a
board exam, but that's
the antiviral mechanism
of amantidine.
so we have the catecholol
-methyltransferase
inhibitors and we
like to call them
the capone family of
drugs because they
both end in capone
these are going to
stabilize the dopamine
levels because they
in fact increase
levodopa bioavailability
because they prevent
its breakdown one
of the drugs can only
do it in the periphery
and that's going
to be enter capone
tolacopone can do
it in both places it
blocks comped both in
the periphery and in
the cns the problem is
that tolacopone given
that it has this
greater action and maybe
it might be slightly
more effective than
entacopone can cause
acute hepatitis so
that's what you're
really sacrificing. Most
physicians will be
okay with endocapone.
If the patient
starts to experience
right upper quadrant
pain, if they get
yellowing of their
eyes and of their skin,
you know to call
them in to do their
liver function test
and you would have
to see if tolicapone
should be removed.
We have a newer one
which is opicapone that's
considered to be long
acting. So instead
of giving entacupone
several times a day.
Opicupone might be just
once a day and that
makes things very
effective, more convenient
for your patient
than anything else.
And then the
adverse effects,
you know, anytime you're
looking to increase
L-dopa levels, you have
to expect the adverse
effects of levodopa.
So the changes, say,
in the patient's
personality, they might be
delusional, they may
have hallucinations,
they may have the
orthostatic hypotension,
they may have changes in
cardiac rate, and then
of course they may
have some dyskinesias.
So again,
these drugs are just
add-ons. They make
things better, they
prolong the action of L
-DOPA, but as I mentioned,
And we are going to
be dealing with a
disease of degeneration.
So this picture
shows specifically,
number one, you can
see L-DOPA coming
through the blood
-brain barrier into the
CNS. We have DOPA
decarboxylase, which
is inhibited by
carbidopa, and that's
going to keep our L
-DOPA here elevated.
So once it comes
through, there's going
to be more dopa
decarboxylase, which is
going to shift now the
L-dopa to dopamine.
Dopamine is here. It
finds its receptors.
Entacupone and tolocupone
will inhibit COMT
here in the periphery.
So you're not
going to get conversion
of L-dopa to 3-OMD.
And then as I
mentioned, the only one
that works centrally
is going to be
the Tola Capone at
inhibiting COMPT.
So this is a picture
just showing, again,
levodopa alone,
carbidopa and
levodopa, and then
all three together.
And as you can see,
with respect to
the levels of
dopamine that get
through ultimately
into the CNS, you can
see that the signal
gets stronger
when you add the
three medications.
And again, that
has to do with the
fact that you're
inhibiting COMPT
and that's allowing
more L-DOPA
to get through to
become dopamine.
Now we have the
MAO-B inhibitors.
And we have two of
them that are known
as selegiline and
risagiline. These are
irreversible inhibitors
of this enzyme.
Selegiline is considered
to be a metabolite
of it is known as
metamphetamine.
Okay, and so that
drug, as you know,
amphetamines, they
can be used for ADHD.
They do have a illicit
use in some cases.
okay and that's
important to know because
if you're metabolizing
to methamphetamine
and the patient say
was getting a test
a drug test they can
test positive for
this so it's important
that if patients
are undergoing any
types of testing they
let the testing place
or the physician
there know that they're
taking seleguline.
safinamide is
interesting because it's
reversible and it
also decreases the off
phenomena so remember
the off phenomena is
when the patient is
going to have more
symptoms of pd they're
bradykinesia they're
going to have freezing
episodes where they
can't move this
really helps with that
issue and the other
thing as i had said
before Or this one
is another option where
you inhibit glutamate
at the NMDA receptor.
So it has an
added benefit as opposed
to the other two.
What happens when
you block MAL-B?
Well, you're increasing
your dopamine
levels. So again,
you're keeping your
levodopa dose
low. and so you're
preventing those adverse
effects. You also
decrease hydrogen
peroxide formation.
And this is
important and I'll
get to it in
the next slide.
Less hydrogen peroxide,
less ROSs. Less
ROSs, less effects
on the mitochondria,
less effects at reducing
ATP and ultimately
neurons dying. and
then it also prevents
something known
as mptp-induced
parkinsonism now mptp
is is a neurotoxin it's
a metabolite
incidentally of synthetic
****** it's got a
long name it stands
for 1-methyl-4-phenol
-tetrahydropyridine.
On its own, MPTP is
not really a toxin.
When it gets
metabolized by MALB,
it gets this positive,
MPP positive.
And what does that mean
is this is the toxic
metabolite. and that
now that goes on
to create ROSs it makes
the hydrogen peroxide
you're going to get
neuronal death dopamine
depletion and and
you're going to have
a negative effect on
Parkinson's disease
and this is probably
interesting because
this is how these drugs
came into development
because they saw
that this particular
metabolite, MPP, was
creating this effect,
this loss of dopaminergic
neurons. And from
that, these MAO-B
inhibitors have been
developed and they actually
work very well when
we're talking about
the management of PD.
So again, I did mention
the MAO inhibitors
for depression
and this is a MAO
inhibitor. But there's
subtle differences.
MAO-B, which are
the ones that we are
using here, like
selegiline and risagiline,
MAO-B is specific
for dopamine.
Okay? So you block that
enzyme, you
increase dopamine.
The MAO-A, which I
will show you later,
the antidepressants,
the phenolzine,
by blocking MAO-A,
they're going to
increase all the
transmitters norepinephrine,
serotonin, and dopamine
and also tyramine
and here's where
the issue becomes
interesting and it
will be repeated if in
a rare, rare case
because I told you that
for depression we
have other medications
like SSRIs and
tricyclics, not even
those anymore SNRIs,
bupropion, trazodone
if you use this medication
you have to avoid
certain foods that
contain tyramine that
can include aged cheese
wine this is known as
the wine and cheese
effect so that if you
were taking phenylzine
and you went to a party
and you had wine and
cheese what happens
is by inhibiting tyramine
from being broken
down norepinephrine
gets displaced into the
circulation and it's
going to find the alpha
receptors on the
vessels. And what's going
to happen is the patient
is going to get this
really dangerous increase
in blood pressure,
and that's known as
hypertensive crisis.
And that can
be serious. You
have to go to the
hospital. They
have to give
you fentolamine.
The question is, does
this happen with MALB?
And the answer is,
unless you're having
a ton of those substances
those foods the
answer is no okay
you're not going to
get the wine and cheese
effect with mal b
inhibitors the mal
a you would okay the
other thing to know
is when we're talking
about mal b and
we're talking about
especially the drug
that we know as um um,
seleguline,
there may be some
effects at
raising serotonin.
And if that does
happen, the patient can
develop something called
serotonin syndrome.
Okay. Especially if
they're given other
serotonergic drugs.
So if you gave, say,
seleguline with, say,
an SSRI, the patient
may get serotonin
syndrome and that is
another dangerous
adverse effect where the
patient spikes a fever
they end up having you
know increase in blood
pressure heart rate
usually they would come
to the hospital you
would give them you
know a serotonin
blocker and they should
be okay but this this
serotonin syndrome i
will repeat it probably
later when i do
antidepressants. And the
other thing is
safinamide. Even though it
has the extra effects
at blocking the NMDA
receptor, it also can
be a problem if the
patient has severe
hepatic impairment. So
realize that with these
medications, you're
not just going to
start them. We have to
understand that we
have to look at the
patient's overall liver
and kidney function.
Not just for
these medications,
but for almost
everything.
So, as you can see,
the MAL-B inhibitors
are going to work
centrally. They're
going to stop now the
conversion of dopamine
to DOPAC, and that
is going to keep the
levels of dopamine
higher in the central
nervous system.
So, now we have the
D2 and the D3 receptor
agonist. I will have
you understand that
with respect to their
similarities their
dopamine receptors but
D2 has more of the motor
effects and more of
the reward and it
makes somewhat sense
because if you block D2
that's going to
cause more Parkinson
-like effects say with an
antipsychotic and it
will have an effect
on the patient's
emotional state.
With D3, there
seems to be more
effects on cognition
and behavior.
Compulsion is going
to be more with
the D3 receptor.
So we have a couple
of them. We have
pramipexol, and this
is a specific D3
receptor agonist.
It's a scavenger
of hydrogen
peroxide, so
again, it has some
effects at
decreasing ROSs.
Ropinavol has both,
both D2 and D3.
Bromocryptine is a
D2 receptor agonist.
You're not going
to see it too much
in Parkinson's
disease. You're
going to see it
in cases where
patients have high
prolactin levels.
And that will come
next year when I talk
about pituitary. If
somebody has a tumor
in that area and
is secreting a high
amount of prolactin,
what you'll see is that
they'll have menstrual
irregularities.
There might be some
effects on, say,
fertility.
So before you can
do the surgery to
remove the tumor,
you would have to
give something like
bromocryptine. The
other thing about
bromocryptine, it
has an ergotamine
in its structure.
Ergotamines can
cause vasospasm
because they are
vasoconstrictors.
Rodigotine is probably
one of the ones that
they like now because
it's transdermal.
So with transdermal,
remember, you're not
going to have the first
pass effect. and it
also keeps the level
of drug pretty, pretty
stable because it's
a transdermal patch.
When you give
these with L-DOPA,
they're going
to reduce the
on and off
phenomena, okay?
And then the adverse
effects kind of make
sense. You're going
to get some confusion,
okay?
Vivid dreams,
hallucinations,
nausea and vomiting
and the compulsive
behavior is
probably due to
the fact of the
D3 receptors being
agonized in the
mesolimbic system.
So what is compulsive
behavior? Well,
you know, there's
been reports that
patients have, you
know, hypersexual type
of actions. They may
be gambling more.
So it is something
to be mindful of.
And then for restless
leg syndrome, they
say that blocking
dopamine will help
patients that have this
disorder where they
may be sitting down
and all of a sudden
their legs will move
without them trying.
So they tend to
give pramipexol
and repinerol for
that condition.
So again, once
L-DOPA gets
through the blood
-brain barrier
and is converted
to dopamine,
now dopamine will
find its specific
receptors, whether
it's D2, D3.
So apomorphine needs
to be discussed
because this
is mainly used
for advanced
Parkinson's disease.
It's going to be
the rescue for
patients that have
the off period.
So basically with
the off period,
they're going to
have that freezing.
They're not going
to be able to move.
I will say that it is
a D2 receptor agonist,
but it's going to
also affect the D2
in the putamin and
the chordate nucleus.
So it's somewhat, I
can say it's a little
stronger than the
other D2 agonist.
It's available
subcutaneously and
sublingually, and it
does provide extra
dopamine action in
these freezing periods.
And one thing
to know is that
it does cause
a significant
amount of nausea
and vomiting.
So how do we manage?
Well, there's only one
approved medication,
and that's
trimethylbenzamide. And that
medication has some
weak antihistamine, some
anticholinergic, and
some weak D2 blockade.
So the question
is, why can't I use
a serotonin blocker
like Ondansetron?
Ondansetron is not
indicated because it's
been shown that patients
that take Ondansetron
with apomorphine
are going to get a
severe decrease in
blood pressure. And
remember, with anything
that lowers blood
pressure and causes
orthostasis, and I talked
about that when we
covered L-DOPA earlier
in the lecture, you're
going to get the
patient having a higher
risk of falls. That's
the last thing you
want in somebody with
any of these
neurodegenerative diseases,
okay? Because a fall
can be almost, you
know, critical, and
maybe some patients will,
in fact, die of
falls, okay? Depending
on how serious is the
injury. Do they break
a hip? Do they have
a head injury? It's
really serious. So we
need to be mindful.
And that's why, as I
keep saying, the doses
of these medications
need to be done very
carefully and chitrate
up very carefully.
And the other thing
is apomorphine
can increase
the QT interval.
And that has to do
perhaps going into
cardio. That
might be due to a
prolonged repolarization.
And that has to
do with blocking
potassium channels.
So again,
doing your
baseline EKG is
going to be
important. it.
So we talked about
the striadium
and the neurotransmitters
and dopamine and
acetylcholine.
It seems to be
that as you affect
dopamine, there's
also going
to be somewhat
of an increase
of acetylcholine.
And that acetylcholine
increase may
have an effect on
this whole idea
of the patient
experiencing tremors.
So giving a muscarinic
antagonist may
sometimes help. We do
have adverse effects that
we need to discuss,
but if the patient
is having tremors
that they really can't
move or do anything, you
may need to give them
something like benstrapine
and trihexifenadol.
And looking at the
name benstrapine,
it looks like atropine,
and atropine is
the prototype of the
muscarinic blockers.
So what are the
adverse effects?
You know, again,
the dryness,
the urinary retention,
the constipation,
the medriasis.
Okay, if you have a
patient, a male patient
that's elderly with
benign prostatic
hypertrophy, If you're
blocking the M3 receptors
in the bladder, he's
not going to be able
to urinate. So that
needs to be considered.
And then in the elderly,
if we're talking
about the whole idea
of what's happening
in those elderly
patients when they
take muscarinic
blockers, we do have a
criteria. It's called
the Beers criteria.
And when we look
at that list,
that's a list of
drugs that need to
be used cautiously
in the elderly.
And these drugs
need to be used
cautiously because if you
give patients
that are elderly
muscarinic blockers
for an extended
period of time,
they can also
develop changes
in cognition.
In the past lecture,
I kind of alluded to
this with the
benzodiazepines and to be
mindful in giving which
one to give and the
dose because again, they
can be more susceptible
to the metabolites
persisting, and that
can cause grogginess.
That can also cause
confusion, and that
can also cause falls.
So I always like to
bring a viewpoint, and
since we have talked
about muscarinic
receptors, we talked
about histamine, alpha
-1, and serotonin 2A,
which I will discuss
in the future, they're
all GQ mediated.
So looking at
the picture, the
example that they
give is the alpha
1 receptor. The
agonist binds.
GQ is now going to allow
for dissociation of
the beta and gamma
subunit from the alpha.
And now you're
going to increase
your phospholipase
C and that's
going to increase
IP3 and DAG.
And now calcium is
going to come into the
cell and it's going
to activate protein
kinases. The thing
to know is that with
the alpha one, if
you gave an agonist,
this is the mechanism
of how it causes
elevated blood pressure
because more calcium
in to the arterial,
you're going to get
more contraction,
more vasoconstriction,
you're going to
increase blood pressure.
So, istradephalin is
one of these newer drugs
that came to market
probably in the last
five years and this
is an interesting
medication because it
resembles something called
theophylline and
theophylline itself is
derived from theobromide
which is the active
ingredient of caffeine
okay so there's a
connection between these
adenosine and caffeine.
I'm not going to talk
too much about it.
This is going to
block adenosine A2A
receptors in the
basal ganglia, okay?
And it's going to
restore balance
in the striadium
and another
area known as the
globus pallidus.
When you have dopamine
loss from Parkinsonism,
this path is going
to be overactive, and
there's going to be
more GABA coming in to
the area, and that's
going to allow now for
the patient's motor
function to be reduced.
And this is
probably one of the
mechanisms of how
the off phenomena,
the freezing
phenomena, is caused.
So here in this
picture, you
can see under
normal conditions,
everything is working
well. The dopamine
receptor has dopamine
here. you see
adenosine is here, you
see a normal amount of
GABA, the patient is
able to walk well.
When you deplete your
dopaminergic system,
not a lot of dopamine
coming here now,
you start to see that
adenosine is going to
be somewhat enhanced,
And now there's going
to be more GABA in
the globus pallidus.
And you can see now the
patient has low
motor function.
Now if you give
istradephylene,
that's going to
block the adenosine.
And what happens is
that in essence lowers
the GABA action. And
now the patient can
move better. okay some
of the adverse effects
insomnia and that
can probably be tied
to the fact that it
is obtained from a
caffeine derivative
okay so maybe give this
medication earlier in
the day and then reduced
appetite and that can
somewhat make sense
if you're thinking
about patients taking
caffeine stimulants it's
not just the insomnia
but it's also the
effects on appetite
You're not going to
want to eat as much.
Think about in that
last lecture when
I talked about the
drugs for narcolepsy
and they're using
them for ADHD.
So AD, it's the most
common form of dementia.
We have others,
we have Lewy
body, we have
frontal temporal,
vascular.
All of them are
progressive.
They say that this
is the one that
lasts the longest
when the patient
is diagnosed. It
can be 8 or 10
years, depending
on the diagnosis.
There's going to be
a loss of neurons
that impair memory
and cognition.
The greatest
risk factor is H.
20% of patients over
85 will have this
condition. It seems to
be more in females, maybe
because they live
longer. that's obvious,
but it could be due to
maybe hormonal, okay?
We do have familial
and sporadic cases, and
there seems to be a
higher risk in those
that have the APOE4
gene, because with that
gene, you're going to
produce more amyloid.
There are some testing
that can be done. I
mean, that really
depends on the patient.
It tends to happen
more in those that have
greater incidence
in their family.
And just like PD,
AD, there is no cure.
There's only a
way to slow the
progression and to
manage the symptoms.
So the pathology.
The
interneural fibrillary
tangles have tau protein.
Amyloid B is really
the villain, we want
to say. It's deposited
in the cerebral
cortex and also the
cerebrovascular lesions.
And with those amyloid B,
the loss of neurons
and the cerebral cortex
and the cholinergic
neurons become less
and less. So with the
loss of cholinergic
neurons, you're going
to get a decrease in
acetylcholine. So the
main drugs that we
will consider first
is going to be the
cholinergic agonist.
So you can see here the
whole idea of the
amyloid plaques and the
fact that over time it
affects the neurons.
So anticholinesterase
inhibitors are going
to increase acetylcholine.
It makes sense.
We have donepizel,
rivastigmine,
galantamine, and
tachrine. Tachrine was
an earlier drug.
It's not used as much
anymore because it
has a higher risk of
adverse effects than
the other three. These
are approved for
mild to moderate AD.
Rivastigmine has
a greater benefit
because in addition
to inhibiting
anticholinesterase,
it also antagonizes
butyrocholinesterase.
Galantamine
also has an added
action that it
enhances the action
at the nicotinic
receptor. It's an
agonist over there.
And the adverse
effects are going
to be that of a
muscarinic agonist.
So you're going
to have sludge,
salivation,
lacrimation, urination,
diarrhea,
increase in GI activity,
okay?
And bradycardia, so
that's a slow heart rate,
and you also
run the risk of
bronchospasms. So if
you're considering
the population
that has AD,
bradycardia can be
an issue, especially
if they were taking,
say, a beta blocker
for, say, AFib. So
you have to be mindful
that you do a test
EKG on them regularly.
The other thing is if
you're giving a SIP
inhibitor, that can
raise the level of these
medications, and that
can cause a problem
as well with respect
to the bradycardia.
Okay, so that's just a
little bit about that.
So looking at the
mechanisms, as
you can see, you
have the presynaptic
and the postsynaptic
terminal.
And with donepazyl,
rivastigmine, and
galantamine, you're
getting an inhibition
of the acetylcholinesterase.
And what
that means is your
levels of acetylcholine
come higher. So,
acetylcholine
will bind to the
postsynaptic receptors.
As I mentioned,
galantamine has an added
benefit that it binds
the nicotinic receptor,
and that would mean
that more acetylcholine
is going to be able
to be released.
And then rivastigmine
has a dual action.
It can block
acetylcholinesterase and
butylcholinesterase.
So, ultimately,
more acetylcholine
is available to
bind to the
postsynaptic receptors.
Okay, I'm not going
to test you on the
pharmacokinetics, but
just really understand
how they work to
raise acetylcholine
in the postsynaptic
cleft and how
rivastigmine has
the added effect on
butylcholinesterase
and galantamine will be
an agonist of the
nicotinic receptors.
so memantine is an
interesting medication
it's going to block
the NMDA receptor
for glutamate and I
explained that excitability
is not what you
want because that's
going to damage
neurons and we saw that
with PD the same
thing happens here but
the one thing to know
like this uncompetitive
blocker. What does
that mean? Well,
it's going to bind
not at the place where
the glutamate binds,
but very close by.
And the reason why you
want that is you need
glutamate for some of
your neuronal action.
You cannot block
glutamate totally because
that would be a negative
outcome, but you
want to bind the excessive
amounts of glutamate
that can be causing
this overactivity.
so that is the reason
why memantine is an
uncompetitive blocker
okay it will in
fact bind but not at
the same place okay
and what it uses as
its conduction instead
of calcium it's going
to use magnesium
okay when do we give
this medication well
in later stages of
AD when patients are
in the moderate to
severe. And it can be
paired with the
acetylcholine esterase
inhibitors. Some of
the adverse effects can
be nausea and vomiting,
some diarrhea.
And again, in those
patients that have a
renal impairment, you
should adjust the dose.
So aducanumab was
withdrawn in 2014.
So you're saying
to me, why are you
doing this? Well, I
need to explain the
concept because the
other two that we'll
go through have
the same mechanism.
These drugs are monoclonal
antibodies, okay?
They're humanized.
They're going to target
amyloid beta, and by
targeting them, they're
going to kind of clear
out these plaques.
The only issue
is that you
need to start this early,
okay? When the
patient has mild
symptoms, when
they have MCI
or mild cognitive
impairment,
you're also going to
have to do various
testing. You're going to
have to do a PET scan.
You're going to have to
do a CSF confirmation,
which could be taxing
to the patient.
The other thing that
is going to be true
with all of these
medications is that you
need to have an MRI
at specific intervals.
You'll have to have
the MRI first, then
within three to six
months have another
MRI. So you have to
do consistent MRIs,
which again can be
taxing to the patient.
It's also, MRIs
are very expensive.
And the reason
being is there are
two adverse effects
that we have to
look for. And
these are known as
amyloid-related
imaging abnormalities.
One is area E, which is
considered to be edema.
and the other
one, ARIA-H, is
when the patient
has bleeding.
So again, the patient
has to be very
cognizant to have these
appointments and to
have these MRIs because
if these effects are
shown, you have to
stop the medication.
The Canamab and
Zonanamab were approved
later. They're
still available.
Okay.
Licanumab is given
intravenously
every two weeks.
Donanimab is given
monthly. Again,
it's not done at
home. You have to
go to a specific
site in the hospital
or clinic to have
this infused.
Okay.
Similar mechanisms,
they're going to try
to get rid of the
amyloid and the plaques.
Licanumab is
special because it's
going to target
proto-fibrils.
Okay. And protofibrils
are actually
considered to be
very toxic because
they cause lots
of inflammation.
And that increase
in inflammation is
going to be involved
in the loss of
cognition that the
patient is experiencing.
So targeting that is
very, very special.
The adverse effects,
as I mentioned,
the effects that
I had just said,
the imaging
abnormalities that
can include edema
or bleeding,
patient may get
a headache, and
of course an
infusion reaction.
So that you can probably
prepare for. They
can take some kind of
medication to prevent
that from happening,
whether it be an
antihistamine or
glucocorticoid. And then
again, MRIs need to
be done consistently.
So as mentioned,
these two diseases
are neurodegenerative.
You're going to slow
the progression.
You're going to reduce
the symptoms, but
understand there is
no specific cure.
So, other things
are going to come
up. If the patient
is agitated,
you can give an
atypical, okay?
And we'll talk
about this later.
Atypicals, again, they
don't block D2, so
they're not going to
cause movement issues,
but they're going
to affect serotonin.
They're going to block
serotonin receptors.
These can cause weight
gain and changes
in metabolics, whether
it be diabetes,
whether it be high
triglycerides.
So that has to be
taken into account.
Patients will appear to
be depressed, anxious.
They say that citalopram,
the SSRI, is preferred.
Antioxidants.
Ginkgo biloba,
vitamin E, I
have that in
question mark.
Again, supplements
are not well
tested in this type
of population. when
they're already
taking medications,
I would probably
vote against it.
Anti-muscarinics,
you need
to be mindful of that.
Beers criteria,
again, in the Beers
criteria, we do
have benzodiazepines.
We do have the
muscarinic blockers.
They need to be
dosed very carefully
in the elderly.
Geriatric conditions,
I mentioned.
It's going to be that
you have a patient
with PD or AD and they
have hypertension.
they have type 2
diabetes, they have
hyperlipidemia, they
might need anticoagulants.
In later stages, when
they start developing
infections, and
they get, whether it
be bronchitis, or they
end up, unfortunately,
in the hospital
with pneumonia, what
medication do we give
them? You have to
look at renal function,
liver function.
And then, of course,
you know, always
encourage preventative
care, like vaccines.
So that's it for
now. I do have a
question session to
follow up on this
topic. Thank you
for your attention.
I hope you found
this lecture to be
informative. I know there's
a lot of medication,
so try to give
a listen to the
question review.
Thank you all for your
attention. I'll see
you soon and be well.